Nicholas isn't Orlando Florida hi
Nicholas welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave he trance and then I'm just
ready few months now thank you I made a
stupid decision about a truckin
but all the other deaths I have paid off
so it's probably dumb thing to do and
cool how can I help today
well my my question today is I'm a I'm
actually currently in the monster
firehouse but my uh my mom and stepdad
on earth in the process of losing the
house and it's only like they only have
about $50,000 is what they told me they
left on their house and I don't know if
I should put my you know buying my house
on hold and focus on you know maybe
doing getting a mortgage on that house
and getting it paid up to it and they
could take it over here why are they
able to pay their bill it's the only one
fifty thousand dollars and I said that
was the easy only income and he had his
problems with his feet and I had a
surgery last year and I'm single yeah
how long are the house then about 57 in
Milan's 46 and so why didn't she clean
in houses only got a $50,000 mortgage
see she's had pancreatitis been about 15
years ago and she has been unable to get
work and the bassy it makes you think if
you take out a mortgage they can pay you
when they can't pay the mortgage company
well if that's working again but he just
doesn't have the credit to get the
refinance house and they how far behind
are they four or five months behind
something like what a year like a year I
think right now I'm making just made
seventy nine thousand in this year and
it's gonna go up this year because I had
a roll
are you 27 okay no under no
circumstances should you take out a
mortgage for okay your stepdad who
didn't pay his bills
what's our house worth well it's a
thousand mobile home but the property is
what the where it's on five acres of
property so what is it it's the setup
that has fifty thousand owed on it worth
twenty thousand okay just being you know
low-end gotcha all right well we've got
two or three options I'll give you the
two I'll give you the three I'll get all
three of them and there none of them
involve you taking on a mortgage okay
okay option one is your stepdad works
like a crazy person and oh by the way so
does your mother I know she's got
pancreatitis but it's time to do
something we're about to lose our house
this is this is when you tighten the
belt up you stand up and you go do
something I don't know what it is she
can do with that limitation physically
what he can do with his limitations
physically but here's the thing their
house payments not that big five
thousand dollars solves this problem at
three months behind on a fifty thousand
dollar mortgage probably $3,000 selves
this problem yeah the problem the main
problem was the mortgage taken in his
mother's name and she's passed away so
now they're not letting him make the
payments they don't have a choice right
no choice if he was sitting in the my
house before his mother passed away they
he gets to keep making the payments they
can't call the loan on death there's not
a death clause in a mortgage okay so you
can get caught up and if they cannot if
they cannot work out a thing to get
caught up by his help your mom's helping
even you giving them a little cash which
I'd be okay with you're giving them a
gift of a little cash if you want to get
caught up and keep the property if you
can't negotiate that then they need to
sell the property before they lose it
yeah and don't be in denial and sitting
there thinking they won't take it you
need to sell it because there's $70,000
equity and then go somewhere else and
get something else and get started again
don't lose all that equity by just
sitting there not doing it but no you
don't need to be a 27 year old go take
out a mortgage for your mother and your
stepfather absolutely not absolutely not
this is a disaster looking for a place
to happen we're delaying the inevitable
now here's what I want you to do hold on
Kelley is going to pick up I'm going to
connect you with one of our financial
coaches in that area who know how to
negotiate
forbearance agreements which is a way to
catch up on a back mortgage and they'll
get involved and help you save this okay
and I'll pay for it it's not going to
cost you a thing okay alright but don't
take out a mortgage in your name do you
understand me
yes okay you're gonna get to sell it if
you have to that's your worst case
scenario best cases work out some kind
of a payment plan forbearance where all
three of you working together all three
of you working to create income together
take all of that income and catch these
payments up because this is it's only a
three or four thousand dollar problem
maybe a five thousand dollar problem and
this can be solved it definitely can be
solved hold on Kelley will pick up and
we'll get you hooked up with a coach in
your area that's been through our
training